welcome back everyone is Charlie they
dropped a new Wonder Woman 1984 teaser
gave us a whole bunch of information
about what's going on with the actual
secret main villain surprisingly in a
whole bunch of details about the
official teaser trailer that they'll be
dropping later this year so we'll break
it all down if you're new to the channel
we'll do a DC merch giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite Wonder Woman
moment on the video if you didn't see
they're going to Brazil comic-con the
first week in December
along with birds of prey they dropped a
little clip - I'll play that in a second
but they're going to be doing a big panel
will they'll reveal even more footage
the actual teaser trailer probably just
a bigger version of the comic-con
footage that they showed off a couple
years ago I actually have that footage I
will break it down during this video but
it was a relatively short clip because
it was really early in production the
film itself has actually been done for
quite a while originally they had
planned to release Wonder Woman 1984
this fall so we would have been watching
it and talking about the movie already
but patty Jenkins early on asked for
some extra time to finish it but turns
out as she made it she found out that
she didn't need that extra time but if
you wondered why it's taken so long for
the movie to get here that's why they
just finished it way faster than they
thought they would the comic-con footage
was a scene taking place at the mall
that we got the preview of earlier with
Steve Trevor walking around in his
members-only 80s jacket with his fanny
pack on looking all bewildered like she
was in London during the first film so
it's sort of the flip he's now the
fish-out-of-water that she was during
the first film she runs after this
person last was them then jumps off the
third story balcony in the mall looks
very similar to the mall from stranger
things season 3 best series trades on a
lot of 80s comedy and nostalgia poking
fun at a lot of the silly things from
that era the Wonder Woman movie will do
the same thing to
the big news from this week though is
that patty Jenkins the director revealed
who the secret villain is on her public
Twitter account in surprised it's not
cheetah
even though cheetah is one of the big
villains of the movie turns out it's the
person that a lot of you probably
thought that it was Pedro Pascal will be
playing Maxwell Lord she posted this
picture in it's actually Maxwell Lord
during Justice League International
that's way back in the 80s that started
in 1987 even though the movie is Wonder
Woman 1984 it's a movie all about 80s XS
Maxwell Lord was a character that was
made to parody a lot of those aspects so
it makes sense that they would go with
an 80s version of the character we know
a little bit about what's going on with
the Wonder Woman plot so I'll talk about
that after I do a quick history on
Maxwell Lord the comics have reckoned
his abilities and his relationship with
the Justice League several times even if
you're not a big comic book reader you
probably seen people talk about this
moment the moment that he's most known
for is mind controlling Superman into
believing that Wonder Woman was
Lois Lane forcing them to fight until
also famous Wonder Woman moment Wonder
Woman is forced to Maxwell Lord to
stop Superman from destroying everything
inside and going crazy there was a huge
backlash against the Justice League and
Wonder Woman for her actions even people
in real life criticized DC Comics for
being this hardcore but a lot of you
will recognize the similarities to the
injustice storyline where Joker gassed
Superman making him hallucinate that
Lois Lane was doomsday tricking him into her in their unborn child
turning him into the monster version of
injustice Superman that you've seen in
the games in the comics pretty safe bet
that they're not going to go down that road
with Wonder Woman 1984 it actually
sounds kind of like the end of Man of
Steel where Superman is forced
quote-unquote to Zod but early
speculation I do think that Maxwell
Laura's powers of telepathy have
something to do with Steve Trevor
miraculously quote-unquote coming back
from the dead
patty Jenkins and the actors have said
some weird stuff about Steve Trevor in
the movie because they confirmed that he
really died at the end of the first
Wonder Woman movie they're not rolling
that back or anything they're not going to
take back his sacrifice but when patty
Jenkins was asked about why he's in the
movie how does this happen what's going
on here she said
that's really Steve Trevor is not
martian manhunter pretending to be Steve
Trevor to me just makes more sense and
seems like a better story if Maxwell
Lord gives her Steve Trevor back by
messing with her mind so that she
believes that he's back but knows that
he's truly not real but she can talk to
him she can interact with him and he can
seemingly act of his own accord and
react to the 80s like what's going on
here but really it's just a trick of the
mind by Maxwell Lord his relationship
with cheetah is also really important
too because the cheetah character does
not start out being cheetah at the
beginning of the movie she starts out as
a prominent archeologist and it sounds
like Maxwell Lord is manipulating her
into becoming the cheetah character and
fighting Wonder Woman but it'll make a
little more sense when you understand
the 80s origin of the character in the
way the movie is using him when they
reintroduced the character during
Justice League International in the
1980s they wrote him is this pastiche of
business-minded yuppies of the eighties
typical yuppie character think Patrick
Bateman in American Psycho you like Huey
Lewis a little so if the movie is
rolling hard on 80s XS think of Maxwell
Lord is the epitome of the evil side of
that based on the comic-con panel last
year and what people have seen from test
footage Maxwell Lord mostly evil
businessman seeking powerful magical
artifacts manipulates Cheeta into
finding them funding a lot of her
expeditions they'll do the cheetah
origin story from the comics if you're
not familiar with her character she
starts out as a normal archaeologist
Kristen Wiig is playing the Minerva
version of cheetah she's actually cursed
by a tribe and gains her cheetah powers
but it's a bit of a curse to that
transforms her into cheetah form
feeling a little slow yes actually I am
then it sounds like Maxwell Lord tries
to manipulate Wonder Woman into taking
care of the situation but the sequel is
meant to be way bigger so this just a
small part of what's going on I know you
have a lot of questions about what's
going on with the Greek gods of the DC
Universe because her Pantheon still
exists there could be other gods or
other demigods running around on planet
Earth then Betty Jenkins also talked
about what's going on with Wonder Woman
3 because the studio does plan on doing
a trilogy and what's going on with
Justice League 2
interestingly enough everyone always
wants to know if there's going to be
another Justice League film this is her
talking about that I have to ask you
quick Wonder Woman question you said
recently that you have an idea for what
Wonder Woman 3 will look like yeah do
you see it being in another period piece
or would we perhaps see Diana in the
future um I don't
III I'm not set but I'm not dying to do
another period piece in like it was
funny I read article today about like
whether it would be in the future or
what it would be its I'm not as our
article actually oh yeah I didn't put it
oh yeah no exactly it was great it was a
great idea it's not it's it's definitely
one of the things we've talked about I'm
not planning to put it in the past again
because then where you going to go I think
it's sort of it would be weird you have
to go forward so it's definitely a
contemporary story that's all I can say
and so where we put it and how that gets
figured out I haven't totally nailed
down obviously Wonder Woman had huge
success and most recently Aquaman yeah
James Wan I'm curious because it kind of
makes sense that for you or him to
direct the Justice League movie does
that interest you at all you know
the Justice League movie I find those
movies to be extremely challenging I
think they're fantastic when they're
well done
but taking on all of those characters at
the same time and the timeline I sort of
hope that we don't do a Justice League
movie for a little while because I think
that each of those characters are really
great and I'm super excited to see each
of their movies and then I want to see
Aquaman 2 and I want to see flash and I
want to you know so I don't know I
you never know I would never say never
but I think that I think everybody
should have a moment to shine right now
so based on what patty Jenkins is saying
one
Wonder Woman 3 will probably be taking
place closer to present day and I know
there's a lot of question about the
Justice League universe in the DC EU
because now you have the Batman prequel
movies with Matt Reeves and Robert
Pattinson you have the DC Black Label
films starting with the Joker which is
now the highest-grossing rated hour film
of all time there is no way that DC is
not going to continue making DC black
label films like that even if it's not
going to be Joker sequels they'll try other
r-rated DC comic book films so you gotta
have this fracturing of DC continuity
don't worry
movie by movie I will explain what's
going on like birds of prey will be
connected to the Justice League
continuity Wonder Woman 1984 is
technically set in the past even though
she's still connected to the present-day
Justice League so don't worry about that
too much right now but JJ Abrams is also
supposedly going to be rebooting the Man
of Steel franchise so we will get a new
Superman film sometime in the next
couple of years but I don't expect them
to announce that till next summer at
Comic Con maybe as for her comments
about Justice League - I think she has
the right idea the idea that they're
going to build up all these separate
characters then put them in a Justice
League film rather than trying to start
with the team-up first then do the solo
films everyone post all your reactions
in the comments below what do you want
them to do with the Wonder Woman
character going forward I don't have any
big updates on the Flash movie other
than they're still planning on making it
and it sounds like Ezra Miller is
sticking around for now but they'll
probably have an announcement about that
in the next couple of months
congratulations Gambino cap oh you're
the giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everyone click here for the new boys
season 2 trailer and villain breakdown
and click here for my new Star Wars
Episode nine rise of Skywalker trailer
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome